savings gives you leverage savings gives
you backing savings as those hundred
people standing behind you where people
say I'm not gonna mess with you or I'm
gonna do business with you because you
got a lot of bad thing that's saving
savings allows you to process things
better
saving the allows you to make better
decisions lead better every single way
you become a better CEO you become a
better executive you become a better
recruit or better salesman if you have
savings in place and savings explain
different brackets it's not all checking
account you got to make sure short terms
taking care of mid term long term if
you're single right anybody I don't have
any kids I don't have to worry about my
kids then it's all short term fine if
you got kids you're married you got to
make sure mid term if you got an eight
year old daughter ten years college
that's eighteen years old you got to
think about these types of things if you
got a 16 year old daughter 10 years 26
marriage in your culture do you pay do
they pay how much do you need to set
aside as fifty thousand a wedding I
don't know those numbers but you need to
be prepared for because that time is
coming very very quickly liquid liquid
let me tell you why illiquid you'll see
a lot of people who all of a sudden
their network will go from zero to 17
million dollars on real estate because
the economy's doing very well and it's
all good so everybody says oh my gosh
that got such a genius he's so great
he's so awesome he saw this I took over
an office of somebody in Woodland Hills
who had in one point was worth four
hundred million dollars Johnny his net
worth went from 400 million dollars to
20 million dollars in two years is what
happened to his network you know why
because he was all real estate and it
was a liquid and he thought real estate
the mortgage all this stuff was gonna
constant go up and up and up and up and
he was eventually gonna be a
multimillionaire that's fine if somebody
you can't go out there and put $100,000
on roulette and say it's gonna be number
22 and if it comes up your hundred
thousand dollars becomes three point six
million dollars there is a one in 36
chance that it's gonna happen so if it
happens to somebody it's awesome that
happens to a lot of people that become
billionaires because they were at the
right place right time real estate all
this stuff that does happen but I don't
bet my money on exceptions I bet my
money on
the ability factors let me elaborate
every 10 years in the world or in a
country typically in America some
countries is more but ours is generally
10 years every 10 years a major crisis
happens every 20 years a massive crisis
happens but 10 years a major crisis
happens okay when this crisis happens
let me tell you who benefits from it you
know benefits from it when a major
crisis happens those who are liquid no
sort of liquid you see a lot of people
that say I never have cash I never had
cash I love cash I love camp you gotta
have a crisis account that's not your
emergency fund I'm not talking emergency
fund that this is the right thing to do
I'm talking to crisis account what saved
the business when we were going through
difficult times in our companies
checking account went to $13,000 I have
payroll commissions everything $13,000
well we're about to shut down the
company it's this close we're about to
shut down the company what saved us was
the crisis account that I had no one
knew about that money showed up put it
back into the business saved us we
lasted we made it through the tough
times and now we're here where we are
today but it's because I had a secret
crisis account no one else nobody the
biggest problem most people are facing
when it comes on to try to double their
money you know what it is they don't
have enough money that's the problem
here's a stat for you 52 percent of
Millennials ages 18 to 37 years old have
less than $1,000 in savings and by the
way only 16 and a half percent of
Millennials have over 20,000 dollars in
savings only 16 and a half so what's the
problem
savings we need more savings we need you
to have more money in your pocket
realize cash is still king this is not
in the past it is still king keep your
cash don't get too aggressive don't get
too crazy don't go to the dump site
don't listen to our Kelly song thinking
you can fly you can't fly nobody can fly
but sit there and strategize yourself to
say oh my gosh in the next year two
years three years five years something
could happen and when it does oh my
goodness I'm going to capitalize look
somebody said well pad this and it's
kind of deceptive I hope everybody
watches this video but they won't you
know why because cat videos do better
somes gonna happen in the next five
years and the people that are gonna make
massive wealth are the ones that save
cash so I'm a cash guy not not always
I'm a cash guy pre-crisis your cash guy
pre-crisis Christ which is which is now
which is now which is now so right now
it's a great time to have a lot of cash
here's a rule of zero the rule of zero
is tough for folks who are very greedy
to embrace because it sounds easy saying
it but let me explain to the power of
zero so here's what it is about the rule
of 0 when 2008 took place a lot of
people lost money yeah there was talk
about the 401 kids now the 201 kid I had
clients I would go look at their
statement they would say I only have
$380,000 I'm like that's not bad for you
she says well this used to be seven
hundred ninety thousand dollars well
that's a pretty bad thing right there
and there's 64 years old what do you
tell this person they got to work for
another seven more years they were
planning on retiring for one year but
because they were not fully ready and
they did not take advantage the power of
zero because in 2008 market tanked 38
percent in 2008 if you did zero percent
in 2008 that really means you did plus
thirty eight percent compared to what
the market did so you have to also be
paying attention to the office your
problem you got to be playing offense as
well of course if you want to create
well offense offense offense offense
offense but you got to have a certain
strategy on how you can take advantage
the rule of zero so when it does happen
you have more that's sitting for you to
say this is my next opportunity to go in
because you paid attention to the rules
rule is road